congratulations thank you with this win
I know you probably realized by now but
you are the winningest artists of all
time for CMT Awards that's crazy
yeah I think yeah it's crazy it's not
the 20th award yes you're kind of
popular Carrie I will a my husband was
like oh my gosh like you're your fans
they they like to vote and I'm like well
that's how I'm here in the first place
like they've been voting for me since
day one since I was on American Idol so
they know the drill laughter you know
have you ever had people come up to you
and say I vote for you today and I voted
for you on Idol like people to continue
on through the years at Lee have people
telling me that they voted for me on
Idol and now it's it's like I was 14
years ago so now there's like people
that are like ever since I was a little
kid I would vote for you and as a little
kid and I'm like oh my gosh like have I
been doing this that long but it's just
really cool that they're still
supporting after all these years one
question because I know we only have a
certain amount of time I know you're
tired - um it's they told me I have a
certain amount of time I talked to all
that about like dance I don't want him
to be mad at me and I want you to get
home do babies but we like him too but
you dedicated the award to Mike because
this is his birthday it is his birthday
no when I say you say thanks babe
yes I feel terrible that this week which
is there's so much craziness not just
the CMT Awards but it's it's you know
CMA Music Fest so there's so much going
on and literally every single day it's
from sunup to sundown we're just running
around like crazy and I'm like I'm sorry
your birthday is always this week like
someday we'll have it I mean I hope
it'll be along I hope it's always busy
this week because that means things are
still going well maybe but I'm like what
kind of present you're gonna give him to
make up for this
no we're gonna take it something good
here I got don't tell him that I got him
an ice cream cake that's coming this
week
like nice that's good that's nice
I might wanna give it a little something
more to but I mean I like know what I
like you guys from Kate we got horses we
got two new horses that's big
I know I didn't get them for him but I'm
like there's you're gonna take credit
for it yeah you got to do that and
Father's Day coming out the other side
Father's Day present it yes what is it I
can and I worked real hard on it it's
like a project like thing not a craft
thing but it took many man-hours and I
worked hard on it
it sounds like it's gonna be special
under your old congratulation that's
awesome
and your babies was beautiful who is
this by thank you and this is Michael
Cinco remembered it's like sparkling and
moving and I like him is amazing